hey everybody its charlie you may have
heard the spider-man far from home black
costume news I'll explain what's going
on it's not quite what everybody thinks
but it is still really really cool
there's a new round of that spider-man
ps4 word giveaway - all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video
so right now spider-man far from home is
shooting in Prague in the Czech Republic
at this big amusement park it's right
out of the comics is a big Mysterio
spider-man fight from amazing spider-man
number 66 even though the movie changes
a lot of things about the comics
essentially it's Mysterio challenging
spider-man to a fight using all of his
tricks that he's created to make
spider-man think that he's fighting this
really giant version of Mysterio that
he's been shrunk down so you imagine
there's a lot of Ant Man giant man jokes
spider-man eventually realizes after he
goes through all these different rooms
in the amusement park through the
funhouse mirror room all the regular
tropes of amusement park bites he
hallucinates all these animals being
real he finds out the Mysterio's just
been tricking him making him think that
he shrunk him down when really he's
normal size and he's been fighting a
giant robot version of Mysterio this
being controlled by the real Quentin
Beck somewhere else inside the amusement
park so what happened is is when
spider-man far from home went to Prague
to shoot at this big festival area a lot
of people like oh very clearly doing
this moment from the comics there's this
big scene that people caught where all
the people were fleeing in terror
[Music]
so obviously Mysterio had done something
really crazy I don't really expect them
to do a giant man robot version of
Mysterio in the movie but remember he's
the master of illusion he makes people
think that they're seeing things so I
suppose there is a way to pull that off
without it being completely real but the
cool takedown callback is that once he
did figure out that he was fighting a
giant robot Mysterio he took it down
using that same technique that he used
when he helped save Iron Man at the
beginning of infinity war by flinging
half of a car using the tensile strength
of his new webbing in the comic book
version it was a little bit sillier it
was a giant knife but you imagined
Spider Man has the strength to throw
really giant objects what's going on
with the black costume though is that
people saw him on set he was definitely
wearing a full black costume now there
wasn't like a white spider symbol on it
so even if it does look a little bit
like the venom black costume what's
probably going on is that they're just
using stealth mode in the stark tech
suit whether or not this has been the
upgraded version of the suit that he
creates himself or this is the old stark
tech suit
there was actually a stealth mode in the
stark tech suit during homecoming that
they never used in the movie or maybe
they cut it out in the early stages when
they were planning things but they sold
a toy that said stealth mode and it
looked like a blue version of the
homecoming suit so obviously it was just
their take on the big-time stealth suit
so all signs are just pointing towards
him either unlocking this mode or
helping create it based on existing
technology that's already in the suit
the quote-unquote big-time stealth suit
as they call it in the comics was
created by Peter in amazing spider-man
over 650 after this big battle with the
phil Urich Hobgoblin there are a couple
different modes denoted by the different
colors that it glows when he's activated
them the reason why it's called the big
time suit is because that's the name of
the story arc that it was created during
he came right after brand new day which
was the first big arc after one more day
when they Rick conned his marriage to
Mary Jane so what a coincidence that
post Avengers 4 it's going to be a brand
new day for all the characters that
survived a lot of coincidences with some
of the things that they're doing
in the movies and things that they're
pulling from in the comics the actual
tech in the suit was based on Pym tech
that he perfected while he was working
with Tony Stark
it allowed him to bend both light and
sound so it's true stealth it wasn't
just him becoming visually undetectable
to almost everything you have to imagine
that he could still be spotted by
mutants that had really deep tracking
abilities or people like Professor X
that can track minds and psionic
signatures but there are a couple of
different boats denoted by lights
there's the green light default
camouflage mode that just renders him
undetectable to light and sound he does
have tech in the suit that allows him to
communicate with his allies so there is
a way for him to talk to people when
it's active the red light mode is just
the anti sound mode that's more about
protecting him from sound based attacks
and then it also has these anti metal
weapons inside that help dissolve metals
pretty self-explanatory but anti metal
in the comics is actually Antarctic
vibranium which I don't think that
they're gonna do in the movies anytime
soon but I am expecting spider-man to
incorporate some ideas from Shuri for
upgrades and future versions of his suit
no idea if that'll happen during far
from home or it'll be a future movie the
only real special metals that I expect
them to do in the movies are vibranium
via Wakanda obviously because Black
Panther is so big now and then
eventually adamantium once they work in
the x-men in the next couple of years so
obviously there's a bunch of comic book
stuff happening during far from home
it's all still based around fights that
he had with Mysterio despite the fact
that they still have not officially
confirmed Jake Gyllenhaal's playing that
character there were only a couple of
reasons for Marvel to not have announced
it at this point one they could just be
sitting on the news waiting for DC to
announce something so that they can say
oh you know you drop a new Aquaman
trailer will show everybody who's the
new Mysterio is going to be or Jake
Gyllenhaal has not signed a contract and
if things fall through they'll have to
cast somebody else it's so it'll be some
big last-minute thing where they're like
oh yeah you all thought that Jake
Gyllenhaal was gonna be mysterious whole
time when really it's this other person
and currently I don't really have any
big alts that I think that would be good
fit for that character but we'll find
out pretty soon the thing about Mysterio
though like him fighting him in the
movies is is that if they do a true
comic book version and he's wearing
version of the helmet you don't
necessarily need to see the actors face
underneath that so a lot of that can be
a special-effects stunt person and then
they could just bring in whoever's
playing Mysterio later to do voice over
dialogue in any interior scenes where
they need you to see his face what I'm
guessing they're gonna do with this
black suit is that in post-production
they're just gonna light up certain
portions of it I don't think it's gonna
be super bright like this blue version
that they sold as a toy during
homecoming but you have to imagine that
what he's doing is is just wearing the
straight-up stark tech suit or maybe a
slightly upgraded version and then he
just turns on stealth mode and it makes
it look black or a camo like that so
they can sort of cancel him out like
he's sitting on the ferris wheel here so
the reason it looks black might just be
because he's sitting against a black sky
so it could be one of those situations
where if you were looking at him and he
was standing against a brick wall it
would almost seem like you're staring
right through him like the suit has
special sensors and cameras that reflect
the image behind him and emitted in
front of him so it looks like you're
staring right through him so the stealth
mode is actually just a hardcore camo
mode venom is coming out next week so
there's gonna be some more footage for
that dropping real soon so I'll do new
videos for that no worries leave all
your requests in the comments below
because that's where I'd love to go with
it and I'd love to go through with the
Avengers as well with him but that's
above my pay grade which maybe you could
have a word or two towards the Avengers
in telling me you'll never fight with
them the venom was to fight the Avengers
like a campaign so please will you take
us on please and if not we're more than
happy to stand alone we have a venom
version nine hundred characters to play
congratulations pigeon meat you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here from that spider-man far from
home video with the Iron Man characters
and click here for that Avengers 4 title
teaser thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]